he's an American author and business
skills training consultant Inc magazine
named him the world's number-one small
business guru he's the author of the
mega bestseller the e-myth he's Michael
Gerber and here are his top 10 rules for
success is the most extraordinary
businesses in the world are focused on
finding a better way they're what I call
best way companies they're constantly
trying to find a better way to do what
to do what they do to do what to
differentiate themselves from everybody
else
how by giving the customer the sense of
control in our business they don't have
anyplace else the clean workings of
Disneyland you know you ask people what
do you remember about the park and what
they all say is it's clean now think
about it they don't talk about Mickey
they don't talk about Pluto they don't
talk about done
they say it's clean now why in the world
would that matter to people because
every place else is so dirty
how did let do that
every night at Disneyland they steam
clean the entire park and they've been
doing that in Anaheim for over 35 years
think about that to do what to create
this sense of order in the mind of the
consumer which instantly differentiates
them from everybody else everyplace else
is dirty our place is not the core
business development system in any
company in every company sitting here no
matter what kind of company it is is
lead generation lead conversion client
fulfillment how many people do you
attract to your door how do you convert
a larger and larger percentage of those
people to become customers and how do
you convert the largest percentage of
those customers to become clients and
the ballgame of that is mindset it's
truly the paradigm through which you
approach the building of the systems
through which leadership and
entrepreneurship becomes a reality every
single day in the company most important
thing you can learn about being an
entrepreneur is a blank piece of paper
and beginner's mind everything begins
right now
everything now is the most important
word you can begin to practice now not
before not later but now and being
present now is the art of mastering your
human capability right now like a
martial artist on the mat right now be
here now and begin it the system is the
solution not people not the product the
system is the solution because Ray Kroc
and Tom Watson and Walt Disney the
founder of Midas muffler and the
founders of Supercuts every single one
of them knew identically the same thing
the one thing the consumer wants more
than anything else the one product that
is true of every great business that
every entrepreneur is there to create in
that business the one word that
describes what you're selling in your
business is control CE o NT r o L the
consumers control over their experience
when they come to buy from you and if
you can give that customer what they
want the very first time and you can
replicate it faithfully every single
time from that point on that customer
will continually choose to come back and
that's the business Ray Kroc was in and
he realized that if it was up to his
franchisee he'd be out of business
because the franchisee he being a
technician would go and do it do it do
it do it and destroy it in the process
Ray Kroc realized that McDonald's wasn't
in the restaurant business it was in the
fuel business fill me up
you got it fill me up you got it he did
it every single time and identically the
same way and it was his ability to do it
every single time in identically the
same way in a clean organized shining
colorful environment that differentiated
McDonald's from every other restaurant
around I want to do something I've never
done before and I don't know how but I
can imagine it
I want to engage in the unknown I
truthfully want to pursue the unknown
and in the pursuit of the unknown
something comes to realization and I'm
never prepared for it so when I set out
to do what I set out to do I set out to
do the impossible
everybody told me you're nuts you can't
do that you can't do that and that's
also consistent with all entrepreneurs
there's always a legion of people who
will tell them you can't do that and
even if you could why would you um
there's so many better things to do
other than that that you can make so
much more money from but money was
really a very very narrow part of what I
was really setting out to do of course I
had to make a living of course I had to
do this of course I wanted to you know
produce something great but it was
really the result that I couldn't to it
that in fact that people who were
struggling don't have to that they're
struggling so hard is simply a sign that
something's missing in this picture and
so the question always has been and I
believe this to be the true
entrepreneurial driver what's missing in
this picture what's missing in this
picture it's always a question it's
never an answer what's missing in this
picture and as I begin to ask that
question something begins to come alive
to give me the food I need to nurture
this passion I've got that I can't apply
and it enables me to see things I never
saw before get the first one right to
get your Sales System right when you're
small you get your lead generation
system right when you're small you get
your lead conversion system right when
you're small knowing that you're going
to be big and that because you're going
to be big it's absolutely critical that
you've gotten it right so you can
replicate it tens of thousands of times
the attorney opens up a legal practice
the doctor opens up a metal
practice the graphics designer opens up
a graphics design business each and
every one of them believing because I
understand how to do the technical work
of a business I understand how to run a
business that does that technical work
and it's a hundred and eighty degrees
from the truth knowing how to do the
work in a business has nothing to do
with creating a business that works and
it is the fatal assumption behind the
failure of almost every single business
you walk into every single business
around because the owner of that
business the founder of that business
does not start a business as an
entrepreneur would the founder of that
business starts a business for
absolutely the wrong reason they start a
business to get rid of the boss they
start a business to get rid of the boss
because they're working for somebody
else they're doing it doing it doing it
day in and day out
a master technician a master auto
mechanic a master pootle clipper and
they're sitting there saying to
themselves why am i doing this for this
guy I could be doing this for me
hell any dummy can run a business you
said I'm working for one
and knowing that you decide I could do
this as well as this guy and you start a
business to get rid of the boss and
instantly do what you never should have
done create a job so what I'm going to
suggest ladies and gentlemen for the
purpose of this meeting that most
businesses you walk into aren't
businesses at all they're a job for the
person who started it and he's created
the worst job of all working 12 hours a
day seven days a week doing it doing it
doing it doing it based upon one
presupposition that sweat equity is what
every little business is about who came
up with that word but a technician who's
accustomed to working it working at
working and working at doing it doing it
doing it doing it hasn't the faintest
idea of how to create a business that
works simply creates a job that depends
upon himself or herself and continues to
do it over and over and over and over
and over again until they don't want to
what anymore most businesses imprison
the person who creates it most important
thing I can say to you about them
growing and about creating and about
learning how to bring the entrepreneur
within you to life and to manifest your
ideas in the world is to truly become an
incredible student you truly have to
learn how to develop the capability and
capacity to create in the world in order
to do that there really five essential
skills you need to develop the first is
the skill of concentration you need to
be able to focus your attention
the second is discrimination you need to
be able to choose what's most important
as to pose
what's least important the third is
organization you really have to turn
chaos into order and you can find a way
to do that where you live in your school
at home at work um with your peers and
so forth
the fourth skill is innovation that's
the best way in other words it's trying
to discover a better way to do
everything that needs to be done and you
can learn how to do that in everything
you're doing today so you have the
opportunity to innovate all around with
everyone you know and to begin to
practice innovation as a way of life and
finally and absolutely essential is
communication you have to learn how to
connect with other people you can't
simply sit all alone in your home you
can't simply use Facebook and Twitter
you've got to be able to communicate
live in person and learn how to do that
you learn how to do that by practicing
how to do that so find a great
communicator and say to that individual
how did you learn how to communicate and
that person will in fact begin to teach
you how to communicate so concentration
discrimination organization innovation
communication and you're on your way
it's like a voice awakens inside of you
that's what I call the entrepreneur
within
which is the subject of my latest book
it awakens it either awakens or it
doesn't and if it does what most of us
do is put it to sleep because it's
dangerous I mean essentially it's saying
fly against all of the odds do something
that you don't know how to do create
something that you've never created
before pursue a path that's impossible
to pursue look at how many fail look at
how few ever make it and um then what
well that called me and I've always been
called by the impossible so I never work
for anybody else I was never on the job
so to speak the only job I was really on
my very first job was when I was going
to school and I worked in a Ford plant
and it was a janitor and I was working
at night obviously to support myself
going to school and I was changing a
light bulb and I'll never forget it that
the boss came up to me and he said you
don't look too happy Gerber and I said I
didn't know I was supposed to be and he
said no you have to be happy here
um that's part of the the game we play
and I said yeah but I doin the job and
he said not good enough unless you're
happy you got to be gone and that was my
last night there and I never had a job
since I've always worked for myself I am
my business everyone says if it weren't
for me there wouldn't be a business they
say proudly but what happens when you
don't want to do it anymore you're out
of business
and I want to talk about a man who I'm
sure most people are familiar with at
least the company he created most people
are familiar with and that's Tom Watson
the founder of IBM you know when I talk
about IBM to small business people they
think to themselves well what is he
talking about IBM for I mean you know
I'm not I be I'm I don't want to be idea
but just think about it for the moment I
think you've got to agree with me iBM is
a relatively successful company
last year IBM did 59 billion dollars
last year do you know what 59 bill you
know what a billion dollars is a billion
dollars ladies and gentlemen is a
thousand dollars a day for three
thousand years in small unmarked bills
think about that 59 times that last year
can you see it how did you do that Tom I
mean you gotta wonder what did the guy
know that most people IBM is bigger than
most countries IBM is if not the one of
the most profitable businesses in the
entire world in the history of mankind
nobody has created anything to match it
well you got to ask yourself what did
the guy know somebody asked him the
question Tom Watson was purported to
respond in the following way he said I
did something in IBM that most people
don't do three things the critical thing
three things he said that differentiate
IBM from everybody else said the first
thing is I had a picture of what IBM
would look like when it was finally done
before I even started the business I had
a vision of what the business would look
like when it was finished you know we
talked about visionaries what is a
visionary visionary is someone who can
see something we're out there no one his
head he had a vision in his head a
picture of how the business would look
when it was finally done he saw this
extraordinary organization its
extraordinary company this monument this
testament to to order to control to
discipline to integrity the most
extraordinary service business in the
world is what he imagined he was about
to create
once I had a picture of what the
business needed to look like when it was
finally done he said the second thing I
did was to get a picture of how our
people would look the people that would
be in IBM to produce that vision that I
had my mom
and he said I saw this extraordinary
army of people in their dark suits and
the white crisp shirts in their black
shining shoes missionaries his army of
missionaries out there in the world
communicating to the world in a way that
nobody had ever communicated to him
before and he said that were that would
that was the person the IBM man he
called it then excuse me ladies he said
finally the third thing we did in IBM
that nobody else did said once I had a
picture of what the business would look
like when it was finally done once I had
a picture of how our people needed to
look in order to bring that vision to
the rest of the world he said the third
thing I realized is that there is
absolutely no difference between a big
business and a small business a big
business is simply a small business tom
watson said that did the right things a
big business is a small business that
did the right things he said if we were
to start our business in the right way
and do it as though it were the biggest
business in the world we're able to act
in the beginning as though this business
were all pretty complete only then would
we be able to do that so we said we
didn't go to work in IBM we went to work
on IBM to replicate the picture I had in
my mind thank you so much for watching I
made this video because Mike Watkins
asked me to so there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave it in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know which of Michael
Gerber's top 10 rules meant the most to
you leave it in the comments and I will
join in the discussion thank you so much
for watching continue to believe and
I'll see you soon